welcome back to CBS mornings where we
want to tell you about an alleged scam
related to cryptocurrency that like so
many scams targets vulnerable people
authorities say that kiosks owned by
Bitcoin of America one of the nation's
largest cryptocurrency ATM companies
were used by scammers to steal millions
of dollars from victims the company its
CEO and two others are now facing more
than 50 counts including conspiracy and
money laundering the suspects pled not
guilty yesterday in Cleveland where
authorities first brought this case
jurika Duncan has been following it all
for months and spoke with a Connecticut
man who says he lost twenty thousand
dollars to a scam involving Bitcoin of
America one of its machines tarika good
morning good morning to you Tony now
crit crypto kiosk are popping up all
over the country mostly and gas stations
or convenience stores now due to loose
regulations police say they're becoming
more popular with scammers who use them
to steal money from people and there's
often no way of getting that money back
and you call this cell this cell you
know in his 84 years of life Artist Joe
Samuels never thought he'd fall victim
to a scam has anything like this ever
happened to you before in my entire life
I would never
I I'm it was crazy it put me in the
hospital for a week I never been sick in
the day of my life in October of 2021
Samuels thought he was calling his
computer company's I.T Department during
the call he granted someone access to
fix his computer remotely and it worked
but a couple of months later he says he
got a call from someone claiming to be
from the same I.T Department he says
they told him that they accidentally
deposited twenty thousand dollars into
Samuel's checking account and demanded
he send it back through a Bitcoin ATM
and they're telling me
calling me because you got to pay us
back otherwise we're going to get the
FBI fearful of what could happen next
Samuels did as he was instructed and
deposited twenty thousand dollars cash
into this Bitcoin of America kiosk just
blocks away from his apartment in
Hartford Connecticut Days Later Samuel
soon realized the scammers moved his own
money from his savings account into his
checking account what was your reaction
the moment you learned you had been
scammed I was pissed right now there are
more than 32 thousand crypto ATMs across
the country that's up from roughly one
thousand in 2018. the machines look like
normal ATMs but when a customer deposits
cash it's converted to digital
cryptocurrency and instead of being
routed to a traditional bank account it
goes to a digital wallet where a third
party can later cash in so I think if
you just educate yourself on the subject
a little bit you'll you'll know which
ones are safe and not safe Connecticut
State Police detective Matthew Hogan
specialized sizes in cryptocurrency and
financial crimes he believes many of
these machines are intentionally placed
in neighborhoods with higher crime rates
why do you think you're seeing this
correlation between the hot pockets for
crime and these Bitcoin kiosks
I think they're strategically placed on
purpose because they're getting a higher
percentage of use in those locations of
higher crime CNET cyber security expert
Bri Fowler says crypto ATMs pose a
unique risk because they are often
unregulated and many are unlicensed
they're you know on some levels not any
different than a than a soda or a candy
machine if you see one of these things
just don't use them right now so these
are the boxes because you're going to be
moving yes as for Samuels he was never
able to recover that twenty thousand
dollars I can't afford to live here he's
now packing up with plans to live with
his son that's what I got to deal with
but then again you know I feel very
fortunate I take the opportunity to just
paint
and put the work away
and he is quite the artist well CBS News
reached out to bitcoin of America for
comment on the indictment and did not
hear back the company's CEO also hasn't
responded to our request for comment
Bitcoin of America's website has since
shut down and the crypto kiosk Samuels
use was seized and Hartford Police tell
CBS News the investigation is still open
wow drica is such a sad story he's gonna
move in with his son now uh so I take it
the money was never actually put into
his account so he lost his own money
when he sent it and I'm curious he lost
all his own money exactly because they
actually took the money from his savings
transferred it to his checking so when
he looked at his account he thought oh
my gosh they did make a mistake and I'm
trying to be an honest person so let me
go give them this money back that's what
I was wondering dreka why would he take
money out of his account if he didn't if
he didn't have an extra 20 grand in that
because that's a big chunk that you
would notice but he did have it in there
because they had transferred it from
another savings correct one thing to
point out I think for people who are
looking at this uh this is not this is a
learned man he is a PA from Howard
University he's got a master's degree
from Columbia University and a PhD from
UMass his artwork is known around the
world so what this is basically saying
to you is you may be scammed even though
you kind of know the way the world Works
they catch you in the wrong moment we
are all vulnerable to a scam
absolutely against hope that maybe maybe
he'll get it back now that you've set
some more attention to this thank you
jerika thank you